Hello everyone, this is Jin with next
level.
>> [snorts]
>> Who am I fooling? I I don't even know
what this is anymore.
I'm not okay.
I haven't been okay for for days ever
since
ever since
I haven't been sleeping well. I kept
dreaming about
those eyes and the board states. Oh,
those board states.
My family tried to help. They they tried
to intervene, but but it's been one step
forward, two steps back. And and I hate
to say it, but I have to say it. It's
it's you. It's you guys enabling all of
this. These dopamine reward triggers.
Make more Ugu. Make more Ugu. Make more
Ugu. Oh, and the sponsor. They don't
care about my mental health. It's all
business. Another giveaway. Another
giveaway. Okay, fine. Let's do that
first. Um Comment, subscribe.
And I will pick two random comments to
win a sweet deck box and accessories
from Kakapopo TCG. And yeah, just
comment anything. Anything is helpful.
Actually, there's one exception and I'm
sure you know what it is. Oh, and what
would be really helpful is because I'm
doing giveaways now for every video and
I'm just picking the winners at random.
Is there a better way to do this?
Because I'm picking two winners each
time. So, sure one of them can be
random, but for the other one can we do
something fun? Yeah, let me know if you
have any cool ideas. But today, this
video is a recovery process. It's a step
called response substitution. A less
destructive alternative. A tribal
commander from the same set, same mana
cost, the same art if you squint hard
enough. It's Homer, our therapist. Homer
will get me out of this destructive
relationship. It's another tribal
commander that I'm not building as
tribal. I I promise I don't hate tribal.
I have a lot of tribal friends and I was
really tempted to try to go tribal with
this because look at this batching. It's
so many things. But then if Jund or Todd
us anything when they're overly generous
with batching, it's because they're
mostly probably crap. And yep, they are.
And this is even worse than Jund or cuz
Jund or is like it can enable terrible
creatures by itself. That was the deck.
But with Homer, we're milling. Yeah,
we've got a few crabs that mill, but the
rest of these creatures are not doing
that. Well, to be fair, they're not
really doing anything. But yeah, there
really isn't much energy here with the
commander. But why am I building this
anyways? Because Homer does something
that is actually pretty unique that I
wasn't able to find in any other
legendary creature. Let's dial it back
to 2013 when I built my second ever
commander deck. It was a Mimeoplasm
deck, and with that I learned early that
milling in EDH doesn't work that well
unless you're using milling as your
enabler or your secondary win condition
where your primary win con is stealing
things from graveyards. Those decks work
really well. But the problem with those
is you need to mill first to get the
train going, but you also don't want to
play too many mill cards cuz they don't
really do anything aside from milling.
Yeah, sure, sometimes you can win by
decking others, but it's really not
efficient enough to be a powerful,
reliable win condition. But Homer solves
that problem all by themself. With
Homer, we don't need to play any other
mill card. We just need a few versatile
little friends to turn Homer into the
only mill engine we ever need. Also,
from the rest of the deck, it can be all
gas. And this is something I've never
seen in any commander, especially not in
these colors. I mean, these are just the
perfect colors for our gameplay. So, who
are those friends? Now, you probably own
a few clones in your collection, and
most of them you're probably using for
our previous deck, Ugu. And whatever
you're not using can go here because in
this deck we are only using clones that
bypass the legend rule, which is the
opposite of what Ugu wants. Spark
Double, Sakashima, whatever it is, just
get one of them onto the field, and now
Homer is milling eight cards per the
land drop. In a four-player game, that's
32 cards into the graveyard. And if that
land is a fetch land, it's 62 cards.
Now, what's amazing about decks like
this is the graveyards. Not just your
graveyard, all the graveyards are like
your hand. And with something like
Reanimate, you can just pick the single
best creature out of those 64. Yeah,
your opponents can play graveyard hate,
but they have to hate on themselves or
each other. But then they have to
consider being milled out as an actual
threat. Because if you manage to just
get one more clone on Homer, Now, each
Flash land will pretty much half their
deck size. And what's nice about these
clones is they're so versatile. They
don't have to copy Homer. I mean, later
on, whatever creatures you stole from
your opponents, you can get multiple
copies. So, Homer enables a mill deck
that can just bypass the mill pieces and
only focus on enjoying the feasts from
your opponent's graveyards. Are you
sold? Let's get started. Okay, to start
with, we're playing just a few clones to
double up our Homer triggers. Not nearly
as crazy as we're going with Ugu, just
six. And once again, these are the
Sakashima type clones that bypass the
legend rule. Now, similar to clones, we
also have roaming throne. This one we
all know, and also Formless Genesis.
This one has brilliant synergy with
Homer cuz we can mill this into the
graveyard and probably mill more lands
and retrace this. And these tokens will
be pretty big while adding to our
lobster count. So, yeah, thanks to
Homer, we get to skimp a little bit on
the enablers part. But we still have to
be pretty disciplined with how we use
the slots saved here. We need those
landfall triggers. So, ramp seems like a
natural conclusion. Also because a lot
of the reanimation cards are super
greedy. They're expensive, high impact.
You know, these cards can win the game
on their own, but we do need the mana to
back them up. So, we're looking at a lot
of the typical choices. We have a decent
curve from two, three, four drop. And
more notably are these cards that can
return lands from graveyard, like
Aftermath Analyst, Wail of the Soul Tie,
Head Shredder, and of course Ice Tail
Explorer. Combine those with ramp spells
that put lands into the graveyard along
with some of these cards that are mill
payoffs. We have a pretty synergistic
ramp package here. Okay, now we have the
core, the boring part. We get to have
some fun using the graveyards. Let's
start with creatures. You can see that
these effects are pretty expensive, but
I'd say we've done pretty well to set up
for them. Each of these can be game
winning on their own. We also have some
cheaper, more versatile effects. Holding
a reanimate looking at four graveyards
with 30 cards each. Yeah, this triggers
a core childhood memory of walking into
Panda Express. Wow, the therapy is
working. And meanwhile, these ones are
not as explosive, but the repeatable use
is something your opponents must deal
with. If you've played or played against
the Scarab of you know cards like these
can take over games all by themselves.
And of course, we're not leaving the
spells alone either. We're taking
everything. And once again, a lot of
these are pretty expensive, but we can
afford it. And also because these
creatures, we can just reanimate from
our graveyards. One of my favorite cards
here is Memory Plunder. It's old, but
they haven't printed anything close to
this yet. Holding this, you have access
to every instant and sorcery in every
graveyard as a response. And that feels
pretty good. While it's not the main
idea, but we can also play with our own
graveyards, especially with these
Crucible effects. And I'm pretty excited
to be able to eventually pull off a
Yawgmoth's Will in the late game. But
yeah, we're mostly playing with our
opponent's graveyards because this way
you're less vulnerable to graveyard hate
and also just you have so many options.
We have around 25 cards dedicated to
that. And once you have the graveyards
filled up, you're going to feel that
your individual card quality is so much
higher than your opponents. Whatever
utility you want, you can just steal
most of the time. But we do need some
basic utility just to cover our bases,
like Lightning Greaves because Homer is
pretty important to our game plan. Black
Market Connection is just too good to
not include. Make sure you try to steal
some life gain effects from your
opponents cuz you will be very tempted
to pay six life a turn and you will die.
Happened to my friend's friend and he's
been made fun of ever since. Some
removal, some board wipes. Singularity
Rupture is one of the very few mill
cards that has good utility attached, so
we include that. But once again, thanks
to Homer, we're not playing any of the
pure mill cards. And for lands, I'm not
a fan of off-color fetches, but this
deck, it seems like they make a massive
difference. Although good news, they
seem to be making more Evolving Wilds
variants. So that makes the more
budget-friendly deck list viable. Aside
from the fetch lands, my utility is
mostly focused on cards that interact
with a graveyard. Like these cards, we
can use their abilities and then return
them as lands. Lotus Field is something
I'm very careful about playing, but it
seems like a pretty good choice here.
And yeah, because of the fetch lands, we
don't have too many non-basic options.
And that's the deck. The game plan is
fairly simple. Whether you get a clone
or not, you get Homer out, start
milling. Homer is probably not a huge
target for removals, but with our ramp
spells, we should be able to recast it
once or twice, no problem. And once we
have the graveyard set up reasonably
well, we snowball from there. It's very
difficult to stop this deck. And to shut
us down, your opponents have to hate on
each other's graveyards, which is the
only way to really stop you. But if they
finally decide to pull the trigger on
that, I have just one more evil piece of
tech, Oblivion Sower. They exile each
other's graveyards thinking you've been
dealt with, you cast Homer, and then
this, and the game is over. This is
actually evil. I'm not going to put this
even in the in
>> [laughter]
>> in the in the deck list. I'm just going
to leave this here
for you guys who've watched till the
end. But yeah, thank you. This deck
while takes some practice to play
because
you must keep track of every graveyard,
especially with some instant speed
interactions. You need to know what you
can do at any moment, and you probably
have what, 40 to 80 cards to be sifting
through. And you might even be able to
combo off with your opponent's cards,
and that requires you to know every deck
on the table. In terms of price, this
deck can be pretty expensive with all
the fetch lands and all the graveyard
interactions. You can build a budget
version, but this is one of those lists
that would really benefit from some
extra investment. The bracket should be
three. I didn't put any game changers
into the list, but I think bracket three
is the right call for this one. And
that's it. Thank you for watching my
video once again. This is Jin, and this
is my first day clean. If you want to
support my recovery process, check out
Kakapopo TCG. You can use my discount
code levels to get 5% off, and I'll see
you in my next video.